so joining me now republican senator
lindsey graham of south carolina senator
good to have you with us uh you know i
guess just off the top your reaction to
that uh rebecca is saying that she
thinks that to a great extent these
sanctions are not really hurting him and
that they work to his benefit because
they're driving oil prices higher
there's also supply chain issues that
are
kicking in and driving inflation higher
in the united states
i respectfully disagree she's a smart
lady but for 20 years putin has murdered
his own people imprisoned dissidents uh
opposition leaders in his country
committed war crimes in syria and
chechnya nothing happened the game has
changed the off ramp for putin would be
built by the russian people not by the
west and how do you get that off ramp
built we're going to crush the rupal
joe manchin has a bill supported by
nancy pelosi believe it or not that
would ban all russian imports into the
united states in terms of oil and gas
four percent of our oil supply comes
from russia we can easily make that up
so what we haven't done yet
is go after oil and gas sector in russia
that's the achilles hill to putin's war
machine so i disagree i think we can
crush the rupal i think we can start
putting his military commanders
under indictment for war crimes and this
is our chance to take this guy out but
taking him out will come from the
russian people
you know i mean when you look at the
information warfare that's trying that
he's really feverishly implementing to
try to keep people on the right page
right
are there ways that we can
counteract that that we can make sure
that we're getting the right the real
messages into russia turn on their
facebook turn on their twitter can we
get can we get that done oh yeah we're
clever do we have the will so the buying
administration's been slow and
indecisive the one thing we haven't done
is go after the oil and gas sector of
the russian economy you now have the
speaker of the house one of the most
liberal people in the country supporting
banning russian imports so what could we
do on the information front yeah we can
get information to the russian people
but the best thing we can do to the
russian people is explain to them what
their future looks like under putin we
can crush the rupal not hurt the rupal
we can crush their monetary
crush their money and we can start
naming names when it comes to his
commanders carrying out these war crimes
take their ass to the international
criminal court and start prosecuting
them in other words if they ever set
foot out of russia they could be hauled
into the hague we need to be really all
in making the war
hard for people around putin he may
never give up but people around him
might well let me play this soundbite
from the president in his cabinet
meeting just a short time ago talking
about new sanctions on the oligarchs
today i'm announcing that we're adding
dozens of names to the list including
one of russia's wealthiest billionaires
and i'm banning travel to america by
by more than
50 russian oligarchs their families and
their close associates
and we're going to continue to support
ukrainian people
with direct assistance you know i'm just
wondering about that you know is that is
that the way to go or are some of them
able to be peeled off and perhaps help
exactly what you're talking about which
is to you know make life very difficult
for putin and push him out
maybe so i like what the president said
but the one thing we're not doing that
would hurt putin the most is begin to
sanction the oil and gas
sector of the russian economy if we stop
senator graham i just want to jump in
because what i'm hearing from the you
know the corporate side of the oil is
that they're not buying it that they're
not buying russian oil that the you know
the corporate side of the oil industry
has already taken that into their own
hands they haven't purchased anything
all week
we we depend on 600 and some thousand
barrels of oil coming in from russia but
not the past week well maybe not in the
past week but we don't have a policy we
need a strategy i don't want to do it
week by week i want it to be a national
policy that we're not going to accept
any russian oil and gas and that will
hurt but what will [ __ ] russia is
that people will follow our lead if i
were president united states i'd be
making a speech tonight
rallying the world to the idea stop
buying russian oil and gas because it's
full of blood
lindsey graham thank you
very much always good to have you with
us sir senator lindsey graham from south
carolina hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else